The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Hi.
My name is Hari Balakrishnan.
I'm your replacement professor.
You guys know about
replacement referees?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: No.
So I'm the other
professor in the class.
And I generally start with
materials that's a little bit
later.
But what we thought
we'd do today
is to talk about this
Audiocom library.
So before I get
started and show you
how to use this and all the
different ways in which things
will break because it's
something the real world,
let me see a show of hands.
How many people have tried to
install or run or do something
with it?
OK, how many people
don't have any idea
of what I'm talking about?
OK.
And how many people have managed
to get something to work?
By "work," it's if you got
the preamble to decode,
it means something is working.
All right how many
people have got nothing?
OK.
Well, it'll all work.
It's just a question of figuring
out how to get it to work.
OK, so here's the story.
In order to do something
practical with all the theory
that you're learning,
it's important to try
to implement something.
Now, the theory we're learning
applies to a wide range
of communication channels.
It applies to radio.
It applies to wired links--
you know, ethernets or cables.
It applies to optical links
like infrared or free-space
optical links.
And it also applies to audio.
And we've decided to
use audio as the vehicle
to bring these ideas into
the lab for two reasons.
The first and most
important reason
is that it turns out it's the
easiest piece of hardware.
It's the most convenient
piece of hardware
that everybody has access to.
All you actually
need is a computer
with a microphone and a speaker.
And in fact, I would imagine
that in the next couple
of years, it'll run
on this thing too.
So you could write apps on
this that will make this work.
Already, we have stuff working
on an Android and iPhone
to do much of the stuff.
So the first one is
just-- it's everywhere.
Everybody has it.
You don't have to do
anything special to get it.
The second is that it turns out
it actually illustrates many
of the problems that
we're talking about--
noise and this idea of how
linear time-invariant systems--
an understanding of linear
time-invariant systems
applies to what we're trying to
build to communication channels
and how you use the ideas
you've learned about LTI systems
to improve the performance
of whatever you implement.
I'm going to restrict myself
to this Audiocom system,
but these ideas apply
across the board.
So let me tell you how
this system does its job.
And this goes back to what
Professor Verghese was
telling you before.
Ultimately, all
of the information
is modulated on
top of a carrier.
And a carrier, as you
know, are sinusoid.
So time goes this way, and
this is the amplitude, or which
we also call the voltage.
So it's a
time-invariant waveform.
What your receiver
is capable-- so
the transmitter is
capable of generating
these kinds of waveforms
at different frequencies.
So this might be, for example,
1 kilohertz or 1,000 hertz.
We can go up to--
I've got mine to work up to 20
kilohertz, which is fortunate
because I can't hear it.
And there's a wide range of
frequencies this could work in.
In the lab, I found
that things tend
to work between 1 kilohertz and
only about 3 or 4 kilohertz.
So that's the range
we're talking about.
So you pick a carrier waveform
for your transmission.
What the receiver's
capable of doing is--
it's a digital receiver.
So what it's capable of
doing is receiving data,
receiving signals from the
sound card at a certain number
of samples per second.
We're going to call
that the sampling rate.
We've used this term before.
The sampling rate
can be anything.
By default in the
system, we've picked
the highest possible sampling
rate of 48 kilohertz.
In some cases, you might
have to yank it down.
You might have to go
as low as 8 kilohertz.
But 48 kilohertz seems
to work in the lab.
It works on a bunch of
machines that I've looked at.
So we have two things.
We have the 1 kilohertz,
which is the carrier waveform.
We'll use the
notation FC for that.
And we can receive
samples at 48 kilohertz.
And that's how the
transmitter also,
when it wants to send
stuff on the air,
it picks a sampling rate.
It's going to pick 48 kilohertz.
The receiver and sender need
to agree on the sampling rate.
What happens then is
very straightforward.
If you have a
carrier waveform that
looks like this, what
1 kilohertz means
is that we do the cycle
1,000 times a second, which
means that one period of the
cycle is 1/1000th of a second,
or 1 millisecond.
Now, if I sample this at
48,000, or 48 kilohertz,
or 48,000 times a second,
in one of these periods,
how many samples do I get?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: This is where
you have to tell me something.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: 48.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: 48.
Great.
So I sample at 48,000
times a second.
Each of these things is 1/1000th
of a second, so I get 48.
What that means is that
we pick a sample here.
We pick a sample here.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9,
10, 11, 12, and we keep going.
12, 12, et cetera.
So we get 48, OK?
So if I were to send a pure
sinusoid at the receiver--
and the way the
sinusoid is transmitted
is by providing these
samples, each sample
being equal to this voltage
value picked from this curve.
And I send each
of those samples,
and each of those in
our implementation
is a floating-point number, OK?
Like a 32-bit
floating-point number.
I pick a number here, 0.
And then I pick
something here, which
is the value of the sinusoid
at this point in time,
and this, and this, and
this, and all the way down.
And I send those samples.
The receiver is going to be
listening at 48 kilohertz
and picking up whatever it's
getting on the audio channel.
And that's what it's
going to be assuming.
That's what it's going
to assume was sent.
Of course, in the
real world, if I
send at 1 volt, what
might be received
is 0.01 volts, or 0.2
volts, or whatever,
because signals may,
in fact, lose amplitude
as you transmit
them over the air.
So that's the overall context.
I'm going to start by showing
you a few things here.
The first thing I'll show
is this grapher program
that actually is
part of the package.
But you need some GTK
toolkits for this to work.
So you need this for the lab,
but this is just a useful test.
If I transmit a
waveform, this program
assumes that I'm transmitting
data at 1 kilohertz.
If I send data at 1 kilohertz--
and this is a pure sinusoid.
Let me do that I'll explain
its parameters in a bit.
[TONE PLAYS]
You can see that what's going
on here is if I'm silent,
the points get
demodulated at plus 1
and minus 1 that
correspond to the top
and the bottom of the waveform.
[CLAPPING]
And if I make a noise, the
effect of noise get visible.
And in fact, you can see that
sometimes the guy on the left
goes to the right,
and vice versa, OK?
So that's actually
a very visual effect
of what noise does
to your transmission.
I'm going to show this again.
I'm going to do this again so
you can see what's going on.
As the amount of
noise increases,
you can see that-- you
can imagine that what's
going on here in the
signal-- and this
is called bipolar
signaling, where
you might send bit 0 as a
particular kind of sinusoid,
and a bit 1 at the other
way, as the other kind.
So the idea would be that the
0's get mapped to the left.
The 1's get mapped to the right.
And as we increase
the amount of noise,
you can start to see
that they cross over,
and we'd be making
errors in our estimation.
[TONE PLAYS]
So things are working fine now.
But as I [CLAPS] make noise,
or as you start talking,
and you create
additional noise, we're
going to start to see
the effects of the noise.
And this is annoying, so
I'm going to turn it off.
OK?
So that's the first order
way in which you determine
that things are working.
You don't need to use the
graphing program to do that.
And this is actually
annoying to the eyes,
so let me turn that off too.
So you run, and the
documentation we've given you
tells you how you go about step
by step trying to debug this.
So let me tell you what
these options mean.
It's all written
up, so you don't
have to take notes right now.
Everything is there.
In that command
line, the dash little
s 256 refers to the
number of samples per bit.
I'll get to that
point in a second.
The dash capital S 1
means that we send--
capital S is the kind of source.
You know, it's something about
the nature of the source.
Capital S 1 means that
my entire information
is sent as 1's, which
means that I'm sending
a pure sinusoidal carrier.
All I'm doing is sending
the sinusoidal carrier.
Dash g just means,
show me some graphs.
And n refers to the number
of bits I wish to send, OK?
So these are all
documented, and you
don't have to worry about it.
So what we're going to do
now is actually to show you
what happens when we
transmit some data.
This is actually the very
first task in the lab.
You transmit some
data, and you plot what
the noise histogram looks like.
[TONE PLAYS]
So what we did was
we sent a couple
hundred bits at some appropriate
number of samples per bit.
You know, the way you
tell if stuff's working is
that line there.
If it received the preamble--
and there's this long preamble.
I'll explain what
that word means.
But if you receive the preamble,
it means that stuff's working.
If you didn't get the
preamble, it means that--
it doesn't mean that things
are completely broken.
It just means you got to
do a little bit more work.
We also plot out the
signal-to-noise ratio
of the transmission.
And that shows up there.
If that signal-to-noise ratio is
something like 20 dB or 15 dB,
things are fine.
This system doesn't really
work below 15 or 10 decibels.
It means that the
signal-to-noise ratio
is too low, which
means you either
have to yank up the
volume, or you have
to go to a quieter location.
Or-- and I'll explain
this-- you have
to change some of the
parameters in the program.
Now, what does this
graph look like?
We'll ignore this for a second.
For this number of samples, that
was the normal distribution.
At 0.44, you could look at it,
and it sort of looks Gaussian.
It's not quite a Gaussian.
I'll explain why
in a little bit.
What this picture show is
this is what the noise--
this is what the received
samples look like.
And it has a mean value
that's in the center.
And then it's kind of got
a shape on both sides.
This picture in the middle are
the samples post-demodulation.
It's actually want you
received at the receiver
after we ran the
demodulation step.
And the stuff on top--
the blue refers to what was
transmitted, which in this case
was a pure carrier.
The green shows
what was received,
which is some noisy
version of the carrier,
because we didn't send
information other than just
the carrier.
This is effectively
the first lab task.
We have to do nothing more
than run this a few times.
And most of the first task
in the lab, the first two
tasks in the lab is just making
sure that the stuff works.
Now, this entire system--
you know, everything
works if this thing
called the preamble is decoded.
So what is this preamble?
And why do we need it?
Well, the problem
is that, as you
saw in this graphing receiver
when I showed this to you,
the audio hardware
is going to be--
what it's doing is
it's always listening.
When you run the
program, it's always
listening on the channel.
So it's getting data.
Even when I'm not
sending anything,
it's getting something.
There's always something
on the audio channel.
So the question is,
how does the receiver
know that what it's
receiving is part
of a legitimate transmission?
All communication
systems need to solve
this problem of synchronizing
between the sender
and receiver, and that's
done using the preamble.
The preamble is nothing more
than a well-known bit sequence,
sequence of bits, that
the sender and receiver
both agree on.
So in this case, our preamble
is that long sequence there--
1 0 1 1 0 1 1 1, et cetera.
And there's some guidelines
and rules of thumb
that go into what
makes a preamble good
and what makes it not so good.
We're not going to
worry about that here.
I'm just telling you
that's the preamble.
So as long as the
receiver is successfully
able to decode the
preamble, it means
that it knows that there's
a legitimate transmission
over the air, and it can
start listening to it.
So if you don't
get the preamble,
all bets are off as to what the
heck's going on on the channel.
And sometimes, you may
not get the preamble.
Now, one of the things
you would have to do,
you would want to do, is when
don't get a preamble, usually,
it's a sign that
either some samples are
being lost because the
audio hardware isn't
able to cope with it.
And the documentation describes
how you deal with that problem.
Or it means that the
sampling rate is too high,
and maybe something is running
on your computer that's--
I don't know.
You have some video going
on in the background,
and it's not keeping up
to read at 48,000 hertz.
Or it's a sign that the
signal-to-noise ratio
is too low.
Maybe you're in a
very crowded location,
or maybe the volume is too low.
So those are usually
the ways in which
you go about fixing this
problem with the preamble.
Now I want to show you
one more noise graph.
What I'd like you to do
now is actually make--
we're going to try to do this
with some music on the side.
What I want to show you
is that as you increase
the amount of
noise, the noise is
captured in the variance of
the Gaussian distribution.
The more the noise,
the bigger the variance
in the distribution.
So I'm going to try to do
this by sending 1,000 bits.
So this will take a
little bit of time.
So let's go send it without--
[TONE PLAYS]
So we'll send this without
a huge amount of noise.
I mean, there's some
ambient noise in the room.
And this will take
a little bit of time
to demodulate and get working.
There's a couple of errors.
The bit error rate is 0.002
bits, so we had an error here.
And we saw something like this.
It isn't quite a
Gaussian in this case.
But we saw something like that.
Now, what I'd like you
to do is kind of start--
when I say yes, just
start making some noise.
Just clap, or just
talk, or whatever.
Just turn on your phones.
Do something.
[CHUCKLING]
[TONE PLAYS]
Yeah.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
All right, let's see what--
All right, we're done.
All right.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I had to.
[CHUCKLING]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: I was
actually going to play--
I found some nice
YouTube clips of a music
group, one of the MIT a
cappella music groups.
OK, we really got toasted
here because you guys started
talking, and we couldn't
recover the preamble.
But we've probably got--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: That was the
noise distribution that we saw.
And you can see that it's
actually kind of a [INAUDIBLE]
distribution.
I'll show you what
this picture is.
This is a picture
that essentially
will become your best friend,
or maybe your worst enemy.
This is called an eye diagram.
And it looks
completely messed up.
So I'm going to show
you what that is.
And we're going
to talk about it.
So let me explain to you--
but this noise was too high.
And the point here is that
that's shown in this picture
here where we ended up with
enough of a variation that we
couldn't distinguish
between 0's and 1's.
We sent something
which had a little bit
of 0's in the beginning.
And then the entire
1 distribution
was spread between 0.1
volts to 0.9 volts.
So the variance
is extremely high.
Now let's do one thing.
I'm going to change
this to just transmit
random pieces of
information here.
When I don't give anything,
it means that the data
that's being sent is just a
random sequence of 0's and 1's.
Let me change this to 200 bits.
[TONE PLAYS]
All right, so we got
those bits through.
And that's a
beautiful eye diagram.
I'll explain what this means.
But the point is that when
you see the separation,
and you see a
point in the middle
here with a big gap on
this eye diagram graph.
And then you see a
separation between,
these were the
0's, and those were
the 1's, which means you
could threshold somewhere
in the middle and separate out
which bits were 0's and which
bits were 1.
It means you're cooking
things a bit, OK?
So you can see that
there's a distribution here
of what the 1's looked
like in the empirical data.
There's a distribution here
of what the 0's look like.
This is not going to
be a Gaussian at all.
I'll explain why that
is in a moment, OK?
So I have to do two
more things today,
and then I'll turn it over
to Professor Verghese.
The first one I want
to explain to you
is what this eye diagram is
and why it's kind of useful.
And why, as you add more
noise into the system,
the combination of something
called intersymbol interference
when noise gets in the
way of decoding the bits.
Now, on this channel,
there are two things
that distort the quality
of communication.
The first is noise, and you
kind of saw the effect of that.
The second is this
thing that we've
been studying by modeling it as
a linear time-invariant system.
The idea is that when you have
a sequence of 0's on the input,
and then you go into a
sequence of 1 samples,
that sudden sharp input
transition does not immediately
get captured at the receiver.
It takes time for the 0
to settle into a 1 and a 1
to settle into a 0.
And you can see that
in this picture here.
Now let's focus
in in this picture
here and look carefully
at this place here.
Oops.
All right, let's do this again.
I learned about this,
like, 15 minutes ago.
So bear with me.
All right, so they
were 0's at the bottom,
and then we bumped
up to 1 on the input.
The input bumped from 0 to a 1.
This is after we demodulate it.
So if things work
perfectly, you would
see at the output the 0
immediately goes to a 1.
But what do you actually see?
You see that it takes
a while for the 1
to settle down, right?
It goes from 0 to 1
sharply on the input,
but it takes a while
to go from 0 to 1.
And then I go up like that.
And then I want
to go from 1 to 0.
And you can see that
as it comes down to 0,
it takes a while to settle down.
Do you guys all understand
why that happens?
Like, I don't mean the
physics of why it happens.
But what I mean is
how that idea relates
to this idea of the unit step
response and the unit sample
response?
This is nothing more than
the unit step response
of this channel, right?
I have a 0, and I've assumed
I'm on 0 for a while.
I bump up to a 1, and it takes a
while for it to go from 0 to 1.
And similarly, it takes a while
for it to go from a 1 back
to a 0.
Now, suppose I end up switching
0, 1, 1, 0, 0, 1, 0, 1,
0, 1 very, very quickly.
And I don't give enough time for
the whole thing to settle down.
In other words, as I
go from a 0 to a 1,
before it settles down into
1, if the next bit is a 0,
and then I start coming down.
And before the next bit settles
down to 0, I get to a 1.
And before it comes back to 0--
I keep doing that.
What I'm going to end up
with is this combination
of 0's and 1's that are
sort of random start
confusing the receiver because
we're not giving enough time
for the 0 to settle down.
And similarly, when
we go from 0 to 1,
we're not giving enough time
for the 1 to settle down.
That's what this eye
diagram was referring
to where we found in
this confused case--
and then when you have noise,
some of the 0's get moved to 1
anyway, and 1's get moved to 0.
And we end up with this
very crowded picture.
The way you tackle
this problem is it
all has to do with
the number of samples
that you decide to
use within 1 bit.
So coming back to
this picture, if I
do this at 48,000
samples per second,
in any one of these carriers,
I have 48 samples that I use.
But now I get to decide how
many samples corresponds
to 1 bit of information?
When I have a bit that I want
to transmit-- let's say a 1--
how many samples?
What that effectively
means is to transmit a 1,
how many of these
periods of this waveform
do I want to use
to transmit a 1?
So for example, if I
decide I want to send a 1
as three carriers
of the waveform,
then in any one of these
carriers, I have 48 samples.
Therefore, I represent
a 1 as 48 times 3,
which is 144 samples per bit.
Now, to transmit a 0, I could
do a bunch of different things.
I could decide to keep
the channel silent.
If I do that, it's
called on-off keying.
And that's what
we're using here.
So we're sending 1 as--
if we decide to use
144 samples per bit,
then it means we represent
a 1 as 124 samples, which
corresponds to three of these.
And then we represent
0 as nothing.
So we don't send anything.
If we do that, this is
called on-off keying
because we send on for 1,
where we send a sinusoid.
And for sending us a 0
bit, we send nothing.
Now, if the number of samples
I select per bit is too small,
you end up with this effect
that I don't give enough time
for the 0 to settle down to--
when I make the transition
from a 0 to a 1,
if I pick too small samples per
bit, before we settle into a 1,
the next bit may show up as a 0.
And then before we
settle down into a 0,
the next bit shows
up perhaps as a 1.
And we end up commingling
the 0's and the 1's.
And we're not able
at the receiver
to tell the difference between
these different-volted samples
after we demodulate.
So we don't know what happened.
So if the eye diagram
is a way to capture
that, what the eye
diagram does is--
it's a kind of a clever hack.
What it does is--
thought I had it somewhere.
There it is.
The way you generate
an eye diagram--
you don't have to worry about
writing the software for it.
But you will look at a lot
of these kinds of pictures
in lab 5.
You transmit a random
sequence of bits.
And then you look
at the samples that
were received at the receiver
after demodulation was done.
The output of the demodulation
is a set of voltage values.
What you do is you look
at three bit periods.
In other words, you
look at a sequence
of time, a number of samples
that corresponds to three bit
periods.
So for example, if I pick 144
samples per bit, what I do
is I take 144 and multiply
that by 3 bit periods.
And I look at that many samples.
So for every three bit periods,
I take all the samples,
and I plot them, OK?
So a particular sequence
of bits-- in this case,
it might be a 0 and a 1 and a 0.
This is a 0 followed
by a 1 followed by a 0.
A different sequence of
bits could be a 1 followed
by 1 followed by 1.
A different sequence
of bits could be a 0
followed by 0 followed by 0.
So there are eight
combinations of sequences
of three bits each.
So there are eight--
you have this clean
eye diagram like this.
You're going to see a variety
of different lines corresponding
to all the places where
different 3-bit sequences
appeared in your input.
So for any given 3-bit
sequence of the input,
there's a 3-bit sample sequence
at the output that corresponds
to a number of samples equal to
the samples per bit multiplied
by 3.
And each of those generates
one of those trajectories
through this picture.
If you generate that
picture, and you
find that there's
a very clean gap
between all possible
combinations of these bit
sequences, as is
in this case here,
then it means that you're very
likely to be able to decode.
Because what you can do is,
essentially, the receiver
can decide that
when 1's happen, it
corresponds to something over
here at 0.35 or 0.4 volts.
When a 0 happens,
it may not be a 0,
but it may correspond to
something like a 0.1 volt
here, which means I can
pick the middle point
and slice it at
that middle point
to determine whether the
received bits were 0 or 1.
Now, if we were to run this
experiment again and make
a lot of noise--
let's try that--
what would happen
is we may not be able
to decode at all.
So I'm going to request you guys
to make a little bit of noise
after I start.
And then we'll see how it goes.
All right, start.
[WHISTLING]
[TONE PLAYS]
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: [SCREAMS]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
You know what?
It wasn't loud enough.
It worked great.
But let's look at what the
eye diagram looks like.
Well, it's a little
worse than the other one,
but I think the energy
is down in this room.
So let's do it one more time.
I want to be in a position
where nothing decodes.
[TONE PLAYS]
[SCREAMING AND APPLAUSE]
Well, 15% better is, in
fact, my preamble decoded,
which is amazing.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: And
that's what it looked like.
OK, this is an eye diagram
even a mother wouldn't like.
All right, so I'm
going to stop here.
Before I turn it over
to Professor Verghese,
are there any questions?
Anything at all.
I know some of you
have had issues.
And I met one or two of you this
morning to fix your computers.
And I'm happy to do that.
I'll be in the lab
from 4 o'clock.
We'll get it working
on your computers.
If it doesn't work,
then you're going
to have to use the lab machines.
Let's take some
questions or comments.
Any people have any
questions about this stuff?
Do people get an idea
of what's going on
and what do you need to do?
Once you get this working,
the labs sort of--
they'll write themselves.
You just have to do
a little bit of work.
Questions?
This can go up to
higher frequencies too.
So if the sound's
annoying your ears,
you can actually get it to work.
I know one of you guys is
trying to get this to work
with ultrasonic reception.
That's challenging, but we
can probably help you on.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What do we get
for the uniform noise
since [INAUDIBLE]?
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
Uniform noise?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So if we just have another
tone on the other side,
how do we get to [INAUDIBLE]?
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
Yeah, you mean
if you were to make another
transmission at exactly
the same frequency?
The beauty of this is that
there's different demodulation
schemes.
Right now, we're using
something called the envelope
demodulation, which Professor
Verghese talked about before.
All that's doing is it's
taking the absolute value
of every received sample and
then running a simple averaging
filter.
And that's what you
write in the lab.
It's a very, very
simple demodulation.
We'll study something called
quadrature demodulation
in probably next
lecture or the one
after that, which means that'll
have the property that, if you
transmit at a certain frequency,
and somebody else interferes
and transmits at a
different carrier frequency,
you're still going to be able
to recover your transmission.
But if the other transmitter
has significant signal strength
in the same frequencies
that you're transmitting in,
then he's going to start
to look like noise to you,
and that's going to not work.
So what happened here is
when you guys were all
whistling and were
clapping and so on,
there were signals generated
across all frequencies,
including the frequency at
which I was transmitting.
And that's what caused
the signal to have noise.
It's not like you were all
transmitting at 1,000 hertz.
It just so happens
that that combination
of noise you were making had
a component at 1,000 hertz.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Any other
questions, comments, remarks?
OK.
GEORGE VERGHESE:
Yeah, we've been
talking about modeling
the baseband channel.
And we've said we'll
focus on LTI channels.
So I just wanted to take
advantage of this being
up here to have you think
about what this tells you
about how close to
linear this channel is,
and how close to
time-invariant it is.
What do you think?
What we're seeing
here is, for instance,
a step response to
something that's at 0
and then goes up to
1 and stays at 1.
We're seeing a superposition of
many such 0-to-1 transitions,
some 1-to-0 transitions, later
1-to-0 transitions, and so on.
So we're really looking
at a superposition
of step responses staggered in
time and going from 0 to or 1
to 0.
Do you think time invariance
is maybe a good assumption
for this channel?
Plausible, right?
Because the stuff that we get
here looks a lot like the stuff
we're getting here.
The deviations might be noise,
but the more structured parts
of the waveform here match the
structured part of the waveform
here.
And what you're really seeing
is the loudspeaker here
reverberating through the room.
You're all staying
fixed, so the echoes
are from fixed locations.
The walls are fixed.
And so what we're seeing is
the step response of the room,
in effect.
If you hit the room
a little bit later,
well, you get the same
response, but a little later.
Does this look like
it's very linear?
Would linearity be a good
assumption for this channel?
I mean this is very
partial information,
but does it give
you enough to judge?
So why do you think
linearity might be good here?
Were you saying, yes,
it's a good assumption?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because
time is a pattern.
GEORGE VERGHESE: Because what?
AUDIENCE: Like, if you have
a signal go five seconds
from a different signal, it'll
still appear in the center.
GEORGE VERGHESE: But that's
the time-invariance argument
that you're giving me.
What's the linearity argument?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When you
scale the intact input,
the output gets
scaled accordingly.
GEORGE VERGHESE: OK,
so when you scale it--
so we're not really
seeing too much.
Well, we are seeing scaling.
What kind of scaling
are you seeing here?
We have 0-to-1
transitions, but we also
have 1-to-0 kinds of
transitions, right?
What would you want to see
for a linear channel for how
the 1-to-0 transition
behaves relative
to the 0-to-1 transition?
What would you expect
on the linear channel?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: So
from superposition,
you would really expect to see
the same shape on the downslope
that you see on
the upslope, right?
So when you look at the
upward transition here,
you see a certain shape.
Well, it's not quite matched
on the downward slope here.
And the reason is that the
particular simple demodulation
that we're using here
for this on-off scheme
actually makes that not
look very linear for signals
that are for channels
that have this kind
of an overshoot to them.
But the other scheme
that Hari mentioned,
the quadrature demodulation,
will actually do a lot better.
We, in fact, saw that, right?
We saw that there was modulation
that essentially pulled out
the absolute value of
what you were sending.
And then there was another
modulation scheme that actually
pulled out the signal itself.
And so if you're doing things
like taking absolute values
somewhere in the middle
there, then you're
going to start losing the
ability to model it as linear.
OK, so linear
time-invariant models
are not necessarily
good for all channels.
It's something that
you've got to look for.
There are good reasons to
try and structure a channel
so that it's close to
linear and time-invariant
because then you can do a lot
of analysis and design for it.
OK, so I want to
continue talking
about our models
for LTI channels.
And still in the time
domain, next time,
we'll start to look at this
in the frequency domain.
Hari mentioned frequency
several times here.
So we're talking about
an LTI channel, Linear
and Time-Invariant.
We talked about characterizing
it by its unit sample response.
And so let's see.
Unit sample response means
put in a unit sample function.
You get out an
output that you're
going to call the
unit sample response.
Put in an input x(n).
That is a summation
of such things.
Let's say x(k) delta of n minus
k summed over all k, right?
That's the general
input represented
as a weighted combination
of unit samples.
Well, what comes
out in that case?
What is y of n?
If we're talking about a
linear time-invariant system,
then it's the same
weighted combination
of the responses to
these unit samples.
So we're going to get summation
x(k) h of n minus k, right?
So this is the
convolution expression
that we talked about last time.
So what I want to do in
the rest of the lecture
is give you some other
ways to think about this.
Our notation for this
was y of n equals
x convolved with h
evaluated at time n, right?
Another way to think
about this-- let's see.
Let me actually
first do an example
and then give you another
way to think about this.
Suppose I have a
system whose effect
is to multiply the input
by A, some number A,
and delay by some number D.
And I tell you that this is LTI.
Actually, I don't have to
tell you that it's LTI.
You can prove that it's LTI.
If I tell you have a system
whose only action on the input
is to delay the
input by capital D
and scale the
input by capital A,
you can actually prove that
it satisfies time-invariance
and that you can
superimpose, OK?
So this is LTI.
So what's the unit
sample response?
If I put in the unit sample
function of the input,
what's the output?
AUDIENCE: A delta n.
GEORGE VERGHESE: Anyone?
AUDIENCE: A delta n minus D.
GEORGE VERGHESE: Yeah, A
delta of n minus d, right?
And if I put some
general input function
in here, what's the output?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: Without
telling you about convolution.
Somebody-- I heard a voice here.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A of s
times [INAUDIBLE] D.
GEORGE VERGHESE: Right.
We didn't have to
do any convolution
to figure this out, right,
because I described the system
to you in a simple way.
You could tell me what
it does to the output.
All right, so I want
to give you another way
to think about a system
where the unit sample
response of h events.
I'm talking about a system
with the unit sample response
h of n.
So what does that mean?
That means that at
time 0, I evaluate 0.
When I put out and put in
a unit sample at time 1,
I get some h1.
At time 2, get
some h2, and so on.
This is a hn, OK?
So if I give you a system and
tell you that the unit sample
response is this
function, h, Here's
a way to think of what it is.
Inside there, here's
what my system
can be thought of as doing.
Inside here, I've got
many parallel paths.
I've got a system that
scales by h0, delays by 0,
and in parallel with the
system that scales by--
let me put it up here--
scales by h1, delay
by 1, and so on.
OK, so all of
these in parallel--
each one is very simple.
Each one is as simple as
the example I showed you.
OK, I've got a whole bunch
of these parallel systems,
each one as simple as this.
If I put a unit sample
in here, what comes out?
It's going to be exactly
that, right, because the unit
sample would get scaled
by 0, delayed by nothing,
will come out there.
Then unit sample will get
through this path scaled by h1,
delayed by 1, come out there.
When you assemble all of
these with this summer here,
you're going to get
exactly that response.
So here's another way to think
about what's sitting inside
a system, an LTI system
whose unit sample response
is given to be that, OK?
So if I put x and n, what is
it that's going to come out?
If I put x and n,
what comes out?
Well, through this path,
I get x(n) scaled by 0
and delayed by nothing.
Through this path, I
get x(n) scaled by h1
and delayed by 1, and so on.
So what comes out? y of n is
equal to h(m) x of n minus m
over all m, OK?
So I take x(n).
I shift it by nothing.
I scale by h0.
That's one of these terms.
The term corresponding
to m equals 0.
I take x(n), scale it
by h1, delay it by 1.
That gives me the
term with m equals 1.
So here's another
way to write it, OK?
Last time, I said
that actually you
can write convolution
in this form
or with the operation reversed.
So it actually doesn't matter
which order you write things
in.
This would be something
you might write as h
convolved with x at time n.
So two different ways of
writing the convolution and two
different ways of thinking
about how the output gets
represented that way.
You can easily get from one
representation to the other
by just making a
change of variables.
Like, let n minus
k equals m, and you
get from this
representation to the other.
This is a more mechanistic
way of thinking about why
these two representations work.
OK, so with that is a
given, let me show you
how to actually carry out
these operations graphically.
In either form, here is
a simple graphical way
to think about what's going on.
So to determine
y at time n, this
is the operation that I have
to carry out, all right?
To define y at time n,
the output at time n,
I've got to find a way to
implement this operation.
So how are we going to
think of this graphically?
I want to sketch the signal x.
I want to sketch the
signal h and then
do something with these two
signals to construct this, OK?
So when I plot x, and
I plot h to implement
this operation, what's
the name on my time axis?
Is it m that I'm going to
stick here or k or what?
I want to implement this.
I want to draw these two time
functions, the functions of k,
right?
And it's just the number
that I'm specifying here.
OK, so on the k-axis, I'm
going to take x and plot it.
So x is some time function.
Here's my x.
I won't label them all because
that would get crowded.
And just to keep things clean,
let's change colors here.
How am I going to
plot h of n minus k?
Well, let's start thinking
about the n equals 0 case.
So for n equals 0, I've
got to plot h of minus k.
So how does h of minus k relate
to the unit sample response
h of k or h of n?
If I tell you that
I have a system--
we had an example
up here, didn't we?
I lost it.
If I tell you that I have a
system with this unit sample
response--
let's do something simple.
Let's say that this is
1/2 to the n times u of n.
So for positive time, it's kind
of a decaying geometric series.
And for negative
time, it's 0, OK?
So that's an example of a unit
sample response of a system.
So if that's h of n, what
does h of minus k look like?
Yeah, anyone?
AUDIENCE: Reflection.
GEORGE VERGHESE: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Reflection
[INAUDIBLE]..
GEORGE VERGHESE: It's
the reflection, OK?
So if I want for n equals 0
to plot just the h of minus k
that I need here, it's
that reversed and plotted.
OK, so this is an
h of minus k here.
What about h of minus k?
Sorry, what about
h of n minus k?
Suppose I had n equals 3 now.
How do I get h of 3 minus k?
So I want to get h of 3 minus k.
So that corresponds
to sliding this over.
Do I slide it to the right
by 3, to the left by 3?
You can tell by looking
at the argument here.
Whatever used to happen at 0 has
now got to happen k equals 3.
So that means a rightward shift.
OK, so you flip this over, and
then you slide it by n steps,
OK?
So you take the h of k, flip
it around to get h of minus k,
slide it by n steps.
So if n is positive, you're
sliding it to the right.
If n is negative, you're
sliding it to the left.
So now you're on
a single figure.
You've managed to
plot these two.
What's the remaining operation?
What you've got to do is
the point-by-point product
of these two waveforms and
sum over the entire time axis.
It's like taking a
dot product, right?
So you're going to take this
value of the red curve--
well, actually, let
me slide it over.
Let's do this case.
This is the slid-over
case, right?
You're going to take every one
of the purple values multiplied
by the white and sum over
the entire time axis.
That's an
implementation of this.
So in recitation tomorrow,
you'll get practice on this.
But what you want
to think of, sort
of the mantra for graphical
implementation of convolution
is you've got to do the flip
of one of the time functions,
slide by n, and then
the product, OK?
So you slide it to get
one particular value of n.
If you want the next value
of n, you slide it 1 over
and go through this whole thing.
So it's flipping, sliding by
the right number of spots,
doing the inner product.
That gives you one
value of the answer.
And then you repeat.
All right, you'll get more
practice in recitation.